[Applaudissements]
merci merci pour tout
est-ce que vous faites face à une
situation qui vous dépasse
est-ce que vous rencontrez un problème
auquel vous ne trouvez pas de solution
est-ce que parfois vous vous sentez seul
si seul
que ça vous fait mal jusque dans votre
être
et si je vous disais que je vous
comprends
je vous comprends parce que je l'ai vécu
et j'aimerais partager avec vous trois
clés que j'ai appris à mes dépens pour
faire face
peut-être qu'elle vous sera utile en
tout cas je l'espère
permettez-moi de vous présenter ma
famille
ma mère qui est infirmière
ma sœur qui est infirmière
mon frère qui est infirmier non je
déconne il répare des extincteurs
dans ma famille prendre soin des autres
ça fait partie de notre ADN on prend
même soin des extincteurs la preuve
pour ma mère être infirmière
ça a été la vocation de sa vie
quand je dis la vocation ça lui a permis
d'être la religieuse qu'elle avait
toujours voulu être avec un mari cette
fois et trois enfants
ça c'est pour vous dire que quand
moi-même je deviens infirmier je ne
viens pas de nulle part ça fait aussi
partie de mon ADN
c'est vrai que c'est un métier
merveilleux mais il vient avec un prix
le prix de s'oublier soi-même le prix de
ce perdre dans l'eau parce que quand on
est infirmier c'est l'autre d'abord
et moi ça n'était pas juste une fiche de
paye à la fin du mois c'était pas juste
un métier
c'était qui j'étais
mieux m'occuper des autres
pour ne pas avoir à m'occuper de moi
pendant les trois premières années de ma
carrière d'infirmiers je ne prends
jamais de vacances je travaille où je
pars en formation avec la même passion
dévorante
j'ai tellement envie de sauver le monde
qu'à chaque fois que j'apprends quelque
chose de nouveau je m'en crois capable
pendant ce temps-là je ne fais pas
attention à ce léger saignement qui
apparaît sur mon nez
et je vais passer de oh c'est juste un
petit bouton c'est rien du tout
ah je suis désolé c'est un cancer de la
peau il va falloir opérer
le plus difficile n'a pas été l'annonce
du diagnostic
le plus difficile n'a pas été la douleur
de la greffe de peau prise derrière mon
oreille
le plus difficile n'a pas été d'entendre
au bout de quatre semaines
après la première opération je suis
désolé il va falloir réopérer
non le plus difficile ça a été de
vouloir vivre cette maladie
tout seul
quand je dis tout seul pendant 6 mois je
ne vais prévenir personne
n'y met mes parents ni mes amis ni les
gens qui me sont proches je me souviens
même de la première fois où je retourne
chez mes parents avec mon gros placard
de pansement sur le nez que je monte les
escaliers que j'ouvre la porte de la
maison
et que je vois leur visage se décomposer
devant mes yeux
mais qu'est-ce qui m'est passé par la
tête pour vouloir vivre cette maladie
tout seul
je crois
qu'au fond je ne voulais inquiéter
personne
mais si je suis vraiment honnête avec
moi
je crois surtout que j'avais honte de
reconnaître que j'avais besoin d'aide
que j'avais besoin des autres
prenez quand on est infirmier c'est les
autres qui ont besoin d'aide
pas moi
c'est comme si ma valeur d'êtres humains
était associée à ce que j'apportais aux
autres
ah bah capacité à donner à tenir debout
tout seul
au prix d'être seul
au prix de me sentir seul
la première clé de si je ne peux pas
peut-être que nous le pouvons
c'est de reconnaître que nous avons
besoin des autres
et que ça nous rend merveilleusement
humain
lorsqu'on accepte de demander de l'aide
une fois que j'avais reconnecté à ce
besoin d'aide à ce besoin des autres
j'ai commencé à ouvrir les vannes de ma
vulnérabilité et j'ai commencé à me
demander mais qui va pouvoir m'aider qui
va pouvoir me soutenir qui va pouvoir
m'écouter
et je suis parti en quête de la bonne
personne
et je savais exactement qui je cherchais
cette bonne personne pour m'aider me
soutenir
ça me venait d'une expérience cette
certitude que j'avais vécue en troisième
vous le savez en troisième il y a des
rencontres entre les professionnels et
les élèves
et à cette époque avec mon projet de
devenir psychologue je vais rencontrer
la psychologue présente ce jour-là
elle va être suffisamment fine pour
découvrir que derrière mes questions sur
mon avenir professionnel il y avait en
réalité de vraies questions sur mon
présent personnel
j'ai 15 ans
et je vais rencontrer en psychothérapie
pour la première fois de ma vie
grâce à elle je vais pouvoir me relier à
toutes les parties de moi-même les plus
incohérentes les plus paradoxales
mais aussi parfois les plus belles
un espace sans conseil pas de
Jean-François vous devriez vous devriez
pas
pas de jugement ni d'interprétation ah
Jean-François si vous dites ça c'est
parce que
ou encore sans appropriation de ce que
je lui dis
ah mais vous savez Jean-François c'est
comme moi
j'ai 15 ans et ma première
psychothérapie va durer deux ans
la raison pour laquelle je vous dis ça
c'est que cette bonne personne que je
cherchais
c'était cette personne qui allait
pouvoir m'offrir cette qualité d'écoute
semi-professionnelle dans ma vie
personnelle
évidemment je l'ai longtemps cherché
évidemment je ne l'ai pas trouvé
cherchez la bonne personne c'est une
excuse
erreur la bonne personne c'est la
personne à qui je peux dire tu es là je
te vois j'ai confiance en toi
est-ce que tu veux bien m'écouter pour
que je puisse m'entendre
mais pour ça il aurait fallu que j'ai le
courage de passer de la banalité
à l'intimité
dans mes conversations
la deuxième clé de si je ne peux pas
peut-être que nous le pouvons
c'est d'arrêter de chercher la bonne
personne parce que la personne la bonne
personne elle est peut-être elle est
souvent là et peut-être même avec vous
aujourd'hui ici
aujourd'hui
ma peau continue
de m'envoyer des alertes
et j'atterris sur une autre évidence
c'est que les bonnes personnes sont les
personnes de qui je peux recevoir de
l'aide mais aussi les personnes à qui je
peux apporter mon aide
mais vous allez me dire Jean-François tu
repars dans tes traverses et les autres
encore
oui sauf que là c'est prendre soin des
autres et de moi
c'est un nous ensemble ça circule c'est
vivant
je donne tu reçois tu donnes j'accepte
de recevoir
c'est tellement évident j'ai eu ça
devant les yeux toute mon enfance
pendant toute mon enfance le mardi soir
une fois par mois j'ai vu ma mère
préparer de la soupe
des pâtes du gruyère et la sauce tomate
faite maison
et tous les mois le mardi soir en plus
le jour des meilleurs films
je pouvais pas regarder la télé parce
que il y avait des gens qui venaient
chez mes parents
mais qui étaient ces gens ces couples
qui venaient chez mes parents et qui
m'empêcha de regarder la télé
et bien j'ai mis longtemps à comprendre
que mes parents faisaient partie d'un
groupe de couple alors je vous vois
venir pas celui-là pas ce genre de
groupe de couple non on était à la
maison quand même
faisait partie d'un groupe de couple qui
venait réfléchir ensemble à ce que ça
voulait dire être en couple avec les
valeurs qu'ils avaient
le plus merveilleux ne s'est pas produit
pendant les 25 ans 25 ans ou ce groupe
du mardi a eu lieu
le plus merveilleux s'est produit il y a
5 ans lorsque ma mère a fait un accident
vasculaire et s'est retrouvé hospitalisé
pour la première fois laissant mon père
âgé de 80 ans quasiment seul à la maison
imaginez un couple marié depuis 60 ans
il se connaissait quasiment à la
maternelle déjà
séparé pour la première fois
et bien qui est venu s'occuper de mon
père restait seul à la maison
alors que moi j'habite à 150 km de la
c'est même membres du groupe du mardi
soir alors que le groupe du mardi soir
est fini depuis plus de 20 ans
la recette est simple
de la soupe
des pâtes du gruyère et la sauce tomate
faite maison
une pensée pour Camille qui nous a
quitté en janvier
je dois reconnaître que je n'ai pas
hérité de cette facilité à me faire des
amis pour moi c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué je suis toujours très
maladroit alors permettez-moi de
partager ma joie avec vous
depuis cinq ans j'ai enfin trouvé ma
tribu
Elisabeth Rosen Benoît Vincent nous
aussi on se retrouve le mardi soir
j'ai juste pas trouvé comment faire de
la soupe en ligne
on est là pour parler pour parler vrai
et pour être sûr que nos conversations
et du sens
et de la profondeur
chacun d'entre nous est responsable de
demander de l'aide au groupe et nous on
va utiliser un rituel qui s'appelle le
Hot site
le siège chaud ce moment où l'un d'entre
nous va venir poser une question au
groupe et recevoir notre soutien à la
fois chaleureux mais aussi sans
concession
chaque mardi soir je fais la même
expérience
j'ai pas le temps d'aller à ce moment là
c'est tellement d'autres choses à faire
et chaque mardi soir au moment
d'appuyer sur quitter la réunion je fais
la même expérience
c'est merveilleux je me sens connecté à
eux je suis tellement heureux d'avoir pu
être utile et d'avoir pu bénéficier de
leur soutien j'ai confiance en eux
ils sont importants pour moi
ils sont tellement importants pour moi
que j'ai envie de vous les présenter je
vous présente le groupe du mardi
et puis vous savez quoi
non non j'ai vraiment envie de vous les
présenter et je vais avoir besoin de
votre aide
ils ont accepté de faire la route depuis
Montpellier Avignon Paris Cannes pour
être là avec moi aujourd'hui
est-ce que je peux vous demander juste
un tonnerre d'applaudissements pour mes
amis qui sont là aujourd'hui
ça c'est pour vous
la troisième clé et c'est la plus
importante
croyez-en un infirmier qui s'est perdu
la clé la troisième clé la plus
importante
c'est de rebooter au bonheur de donner
lorsqu'on accepte de recevoir
généreusement
j'insiste sur généreusement
si je ne peux pas peut-être que nous le
pouvons ça a été pour moi d'entrer en
amitié avec mes limites
parce que j'ai découvert qu'il y a une
force à se reconnaître fragile
que c'est dans mes failles
que la lumière des autres peut rentrer
j'ai arrêté de chercher les bonnes
personnes elles étaient déjà là
je continue de prendre soin ça fait
partie de mon ADN
mais aujourd'hui mon ADN à deux brins
donner et recevoir
et ça ça réenchante mon monde
pour terminer j'aimerais reprendre les
paroles de Grand Corps Malade en tant
qu'infirmier qui d'autre vous pouvez
choisir
les hommes sont plus forts quand ils
connaissent leur faiblesse
chaque interaction est féconde
dis-leur que l'entraide et le partage
c'est l'avenir de l'espèce
quand la vie est trop lourde portons là
à plusieurs
tout seul je vais vite
ensemble on va plus loin
quand je fais ma partie je peux passer
le témoin
tout seul je résiste
ensemble on craint rien
on apprend on grandit
et on rigole bien
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]